WE HAVE A LOT TO GET TO TONIGHT.
HE'S BEEN IN THE FOREFRONT OF
ALL THIS, LINDSEY GRAHAM.
WELCOME, IT IS GOOD TO BE BACK.
TO ME THIS IS SERIOUS.
WHAT WAS THE DEAL ON FRIDAY?
>> HERE'S THE DEAL.
SENATOR FLAKE VOTED YES ON THE
COMMITTEE WITH THE UNDERSTANDING
THAT SHE WOULD LIKE THE FBI TO
INTERVIEW THE 340 WITNESSES THAT
WERE INTERVIEWED BY THE
REPUBLICAN ON THE COMMITTEE.
PJ, MRS. LELAND, AND MARK JUDGE.
LISA MURKOWSKI SET OUT THAT THE
FBI TO TRY TO CHECK THE
COMMITTEE'S HOMEWORK AND BE ALSO
AGREED TO INTERVIEW MRS. RAMIREZ
WITH THE ALLEGATIONS.
>> Hannity: THAT WAS THE
NEW YORKER?
>> RIGHT.
IF THEY WON'T FURTHER INTERVIEW,
THEY WILL SIT DOWN WITH
SENATOR McCONNELL AND SEE WHAT
THEY CAN WORK OUT.
THEY HAD A DEAL FOR A WEEK, WE
LIMITED THE INTERVIEWS TWO,
THREE PEOPLE NAMED BY DR. FORD.
WE WILL SEE WITH THE FBI FINDS.
>> Hannity: IT IS NOW BEEN
EXPANDED OUT?
THE PRESIDENT SAID.
>> NO IT IS NOT.
THIS IS A REQUEST OUT OF
SIGNAGE.
NOBODY ASKED TO DO THIS.
NOBODY ASKED FOR THAT.
NOT ONE DEMOCRAT ASKED THE
QUESTION.
THE SENATORS ENGLISH AND DID NOT
FEEL THAT WAS NECESSARY.
IT MAKES NO SENSE
LET ME GO OVER IT AGAIN.
THE DOCTOR FORD WITNESSES, MARK
JUDGE, LELAND, AND PJ.
AND MRS. RAMIREZ.
THAT SAID, DO IT WITHIN A WEEK,
REPORT BACK TO THE SENATE AND
WILL MOVE FORWARD.
NBC NEWS JUST RAN THIS
INTERVIEW.
>> Hannity: NOT ONLY WAS ONE
PERSON TO HEADSET, SHE CHANGED
THE STORY.
SHE WAS SAYING THAT IT WAS
SYSTEMATICALLY --
EVERY WEEKEND.
>> WE CAN TAKE CARE OF THIS IN
ABOUT 30 SECONDS.
WHAT REASONABLE PERSON WOULD GO
TO A PARTY, WITNESS DRUGGING OF
WOMEN, GANG RAPE AND GO BACK.
I NEVER TELL ANYBODY.
>> Hannity: AND NOW SHE IS
SAYING, SAID THAT HE PUT IT IN
THE PUNCH.
HE WAS NEAR THE PUNCH.
WHAT IS NBC RUN THIS?
>> THERE WAS AN ANONYMOUS LETTER
RECEIVED BY CORY GARDNER, THE
SENATOR FROM COLORADO WITH NO
RETURN ADDRESS, JUST A LETTER.
IT ACCUSED BRETT KAVANAUGH OF
ASSAULTING SOMEBODY IN A
RESTAURANT IN 1998 IN COLORADO.
CORY HANDED TO THE COMMITTEE AND
SOMEBODY ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
LEAKED THAT A LETTER.
I GOT ON THE NBC NIGHTLY NEWS.
THE FOURTH ALLEGATION.
>> Hannity: THE FIFTH AND
RHODE ISLAND.
>> TO THINK NBC WOULD HAVE DONE
THAT IF IT WAS A DEMOCRATIC MALE
NOMINEE?
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT THE
JOURNALIST INTEGRITY HAS BEEN
DESTROYED OVER THIS CASE.
>> Hannity: ALL RIGHT.
IT IS A VERY TIGHT MARGIN IN THE
SENATE.
>> ANY OF JEFF FLAKE.
>> Hannity: WHO KNOWS WHAT
JEFF FLAKE IS SAYING.
WHO KNOWS.
LET ME ASK YOU THIS, YOU FALL
ONE VOTE SHORT.
>> NUMBER ONE, I DON'T THINK WE
WILL.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY, I DON'T
THINK WE WILL FIND ANYTHING NEW
FROM THE SUPPLEMENT ON THE FBI
INVESTIGATION TO TAKE JEFF FROM
YES, TO KNOW.
I THINK THE TWO SENATORS WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE FBI DID THEIR
HOMEWORK, THEY CHECKED THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK.
BUT HER WORK WAS GOOD.
I THINK THAT IS WHAT THIS IS ALL
ABOUT.
WE'RE NOT EXPANDING AT ALL THIS
CRAZY STUFF.
NOW, WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF
SOMETHING REALLY WEIRD DID
OCCUR.
WE ARE ONE VOTE SHORT.
HERE'S WHAT I WOULD DO, I WOULD
APPEAL THE VERDICT TO THE BALLOT
BOX.
THIS GOOD MAN SHOULD NOT BE
DESTROYED IF YOU LEGITIMIZE THIS
PROCESS BY ONE VOTE SHORT.
WE WILL BE ON TO THE NEXT
PERSON.
I WOULD HATE TO BE THE NEXT
PERSON NOMINATED.
I WOULD FEEL HORRIBLE THAT WE
DESTROYED BRETT KAVANAUGH.
WHAT WOULD I DO?
I WOULD RENOMINATE HIM AND I
WOULD TAKE THIS CASE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND VOTERS IN
INDIANA AND MISSOURI AND
NORTH DAKOTA AND OTHER PLACES
WHERE TRUMP ONE SAYING WHO HE
WOULD NOMINATE IF HE GOT
PRESIDENT AND SEE IF VOTERS WANT
TO APPEAL THE VERDICT.
>> Hannity: YOU ARE SAYING IF
YOU FALL ONE VOTE SHORT, YOU ARE
SAYING THAT I WOULD APPEAL THE
CASE.
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD RENOMIN
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD RENOMIT
FOR THIS ELECTION?
>> THE PRESIDENT SHOULD RENOMI?
>> ONE YOU WOULD BE LEGITIMIZING
DESTRUCTION OF A HORRIBLE
PERSON, I MEAN A HORRIBLE
PROCESS AT A GOOD PROP MIKE
PERSON.
>> Hannity: THIS WOULD BE A
REFERENDUM?
>> THIS WOULD BE AN APPEAL FROM
A POLITICAL BODY TO THE PEOPLE
WHO PUT US HERE AND SEE IF THESE
TRUMP STATES THAT ELECTED
PRESIDENT TRUMP WOULD DO EXACTLY
WHAT HE IS DOING ON CUTTING
TAXES.
IF THEY ARE OKAY WITH THE
DECISION OF THEIR SENATOR, I
DON'T THINK WE WILL GET THERE.
I THINK WE WILL GET 50 PLUS BUT
IF WE FELL ONE VOTE SHORT FOR
THE GOOD OF THE NATION, I WOULD